* Instrumentalversion
von "Vogel-Lisi" *
* Rockmusik "Vogellisi"
von Buurebüebli *
# S'Berner Oberland isch schön.
# S'Oberland, ja s'Oberland,
s'Berner Oberland isch schön.
Ehrlich gesagt: Wir als Einheimische
mögen sie nicht so.
Weil diese Tuch-Frauen und so ...
Das ist mühsam.
Wenn man in Interlaken spaziert,
trifft man nur auf solche.
Einheimische hat es fast keine mehr.
Das ist schade.
Jede Religion kauft hier ein
und hat hier Spass in den Ferien.
Hier funktioniert es.
Ich hätte es lieber noch bunter und
gemischter. Das wäre noch schöner.
Interlaken boomt,
die Besucher kommen aus aller Welt.
Kann ein Tourismusort
zu viele Gäste haben?
Oder sind es die Falschen?
Mit diesen Fragen bin ich
ins Berner Oberland gefahren.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Die Einheimischen unter sich zu
finden, ist nicht mehr so einfach.
Ich versuche es
bei den Proben der Tellspiele,
die hier eine
über 100 Jahre alte Tradition haben.
Die meisten Schauspielerinnen und
Schauspieler sind aus der Region
und viele im Tourismus tätig.
Man sei sich der zentralen Bedeutung
des Tourismus durchaus bewusst,
sagt Theaterleiter und
Tell-Darsteller Pascal Minder.
Aus einer historischen Perspektive
könne man den derzeitigen Boom
aber auch kritisch beobachten.
Was würde Tell
zum heutigen Interlaken sagen?
Er würde vielleicht
nur den Kopf schütteln.
Die Habsburger haben ja zu
weiten Teilen die Schweiz regiert
und die Eidgenossen
zur damaligen Zeit unterdrückt.
Und Tell musste sich
auch wehren und standhaft sein.
Und in gewissem Sinne müssen das
die Einheimischen heute auch noch,
müssen schauen, dass sie zu
ihrem Recht kommen. Wer weiss?
Bei den Tell-Freilichtspielen sind
sind die meisten Besucher Schweizer.
Ausländische Touristen
sind hier selten zu Gast.
Aber im Alltag kommen die
einheimischen Laiendarsteller
fast täglich mit den vielen
internationalen Besuchern in Kontakt.
Es ist, wie es ist im Tourismus.
Einerseits bringt es Geld,
und andererseits kommen Leute.
Würden Sie lieber
nur das Geld nehmen?
Das wird Ihnen niemand je so sagen.
Nein, es ist eben so:
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass Interlaken eigentlich
nicht ein so grosser Ort ist.
Und wenn die Touristen da sind,
ist es doch sehr belebt.
Und das gibt da und dort Konflikte.
Das ist so.
Aber es gehört
zu einer Tourismusregion.
Und wie sehen die Konflikte aus?
Häufig ist es, dass man die Anderen,
dass man die Gäste
nicht so recht verstehen kann,
dass man sie zu wenig kennt.
Und in den letzten Jahren
kamen Gäste von wirklich weit her,
die eine ganz fremde Kultur haben.
Und damit tut sich
der eine oder andere etwas schwer.
Aber ist das eher ein Gefühl?
Oder ist es etwas,
das man im Alltag konkret merkt?
Es ist natürlich je nachdem ...
Z.B. verhüllte Frauen?
Das ist sicher etwas,
das man sich nicht so gewohnt ist.
Und was noch?
Ja, es sind ...
Touristen, die vielleicht
immer dasselbe fragen.
Ja, ich habe schon gehört,
dass es z.B. Leute gibt,
die gar nicht wissen,
wie man hier Toiletten braucht.
Jetzt muss ich aber aufpassen,
dass ich den Einsatz nicht verpasse.
Wie heissen Sie?
- Alfred Siegrist.
* Rufe und Geschrei *
Es will nicht. Es pickt mich.
Der Kopf ist lose.
So, jetzt ist gut.
Abgesehen vom Theater -
wie erleben Sie den Tourismus,
wenn Sie ihn mit früher vergleichen?
Mir hat es langsam aber sicher
viel zu viele Touristen.
Früher hatten wir im Winter
hier in Interlaken überhaupt keine.
Sie waren alle in Grindelwald,
Lauterbrunnen, Mürren und Wengen.
In Interlaken haben
die grossen Hotels dichtgemacht.
Aber langsam kamen
immer mehr Touristen.
Und jetzt werden wir
total überrannt.
Es ist nicht mehr so schön.
Wieso? Was ist nicht schön?
Also wir haben eigentlich
keine Läden mehr für uns.
Alle Geschäfte sind
rein auf Tourismus eingestellt.
Es spielt keine Rolle,
worum es geht.
Es hat nur noch Uhren-
und Schmuckgeschäfte usw.
Aber die Geschäfte,
die wir Einheimische brauchen,
wurden grösstenteils ausradiert.
Was ich ganz schlimm finde, ist,
dass die Einheimischen ihre Hotels
an Inder oder Araber verkaufen -
und eben auch die Geschäfte.
Das finde ich also etwas bedenklich.
Am Schluss gehört den Schweizern
nichts mehr hier in Interlaken.
Einer, der Hotels
an Ausländer vermittelt,
ist Jürg Zumkehr
von der Firma hotelforsale.
Dort vorne ist das Hotel Crystal.
Die Besitzerin dieses Hotels
sagte beispielsweise,
sie wolle es
einem Schweizer verkaufen.
Und sie sei bereit, es diesem
wesentlich günstiger zu geben.
Leider ging es am Schluss
trotzdem in ausländische Hand über.
Auch das Hotel Krebs
ging vor Jahren an Ausländer,
wie jedes zweite verkaufte Hotel
in letzter Zeit.
Ein Ehepaar aus Südkorea
hat es gekauft
und danach für 7 Mio. Fr. renoviert.
Es laufe gut, sagt Zumkehr.
Wir haben alle 44 Zimmer im Stil
renoviert, wie Sie es hier sehen.
Inklusive schöne Badezimmer,
Sie sagen, das Hotel rentiere.
Wieso haben dann
keine Schweizer mehr geboten?
Die Schweizer sind weniger bereit,
Risiken einzugehen.
Sehr oft fehlt es
am nötigen Eigenkapital.
Und sehr oft
sind die Banken nicht bereit,
über den Ertragswert hinaus
zu finanzieren.
Wie fielen damals die Reaktionen aus,
als es hiess,
das Hotel Krebs
gehe an einen Koreaner
und sei nicht mehr
in einheimischer Hand?
"Muss das jetzt
ein Auswärtiger sein?"
Ja, diese Frage
wird immer wieder gestellt.
Darauf antworte ich jeweils:
"Bringt mir Schweizer Kunden."
Ich verkaufe die Hotels
auch lieber an Schweizer.
Die Realität ist eben etwas anders.
Sehr oft bin einfach ich schuld,
weil ich den Kunden gebracht habe.
Aber ...
Hier sehen Sie zwei Sachen.
Einerseits die Verbindung
von Alt und Neu.
Das beliessen wir so,
weil es schon früher so war und
von den Gästen sehr geschätzt wird.
Und vom Denkmalschutz her
mussten wir uns verpflichten,
den knarrenden Holzboden
so bestehen zu lassen.
Und daran haben die Gäste
auch Freude?
Ja.
- Am Knarren zur Geisterstunde?
Ja, zur Geisterstunde,
das ist etwas anderes.
Hier haben wir
ein weiteres Unikat in diesem Hotel:
der Ringgenberger Stein.
Das ist etwas sehr Seltenes.
Auch diesen mussten wir wegen
der Denkmalpflege stehen lassen.
Sie sehen hier diese Treppe
aus Ringgenberger Stein.
Was sagte der Koreaner,
als er den Ringgenberger Stein
bestehen lassen musste?
Er sagte: "Wenn das die Leute
von der Denkmalpflege wollen,
dann akzeptieren wir das."
Aber prallen da
nicht Kulturen aufeinander?
Selten. Wenn man es
erklärt und begründet,
kann man die Leute
eigentlich auch überzeugen.
Viele ausländische Hotelbesitzer
scheuten die Öffentlichkeit,
meint Zumkehr.
Er hatte mehrere angefragt,
aber niemand wollte vor die Kamera.
Aus dieser Bank hier, sehen Sie,
wurde jetzt ein Laden.
Sie sind ja auch SVP-Politiker.
Wie geht das zusammen:
SVP und Ausverkauf der Heimat?
Das verträgt sich sehr gut.
- Verträgt sich das?
Wenn es um grosse Objekte geht,
stelle ich einfach fest,
dass die Schweizer nicht da sind.
Darum kann ich das gut vertreten.
Gibt es parteiintern keine Kritik?
Doch, das gab es auch schon,
das muss ich zugeben.
Ich würde lügen,
wenn ich das abstritte.
Was sagen Ihre Parteikollegen?
Sie fragen: "Muss das sein?"
Und ich antworte:
"Was wollt ihr denn?"
"Wollt ihr,
dass ein Hotel leer steht?"
"Oder wollt ihr,
dass es gekauft wird,
dass 7 Mio. investiert werden,
um danach
für Touristen und Einheimische
als Gast oder Hotelgast
wieder zur Verfügung zu stehen?
Ausländer sind also willkommen,
wenn sie Geld bringen?
Die Ausländer ...
Da kommen auch andere,
die ohne Geld in die Schweiz kommen.
Aber darüber will ich jetzt
nicht sprechen.
Ganz aktuell ist der Verkauf
des traditionsreichen Hotels Sonne
in Matten bei Interlaken.
Im Frühling ging es
an Käufer aus Indien,
zum Bedauern des Gemeinderates.
Die ausländischen Käufer
erhielt damit
auch die Wirterechte fürs Eishockey-
Stadion und für die Tell-Festspiele.
Wie es bei den Tell-Spielen
nun mit der Verpflegung weitergeht,
ist ungewiss.
Es ist unglücklich gelaufen,
aber ich muss so sagen:
Man muss mit ihnen reden.
Mit diesen Leute muss man reden.
Mit diesen Leute kann man reden.
Aber es ist ungewohnt, im eigenen Ort
jetzt auf Fremde zugehen zu müssen.
Nein, die Fremden gehen manchmal
auch auf die Einheimischen zu.
Aber es gilt auch
das umgekehrte Recht.
Man hat auch die Möglichkeit,
auf die Fremden zuzugehen.
Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass man doch eine Lösung findet.
In Interlaken
sind in den letzten Jahren
die Immobilienpreise
überdurchschnittlich gestiegen.
Zudem werden inzwischen
Hunderte von Wohnungen
über die Online-Plattform Airbnb
vermietet.
Die Gemeinde war gezwungen,
hier klarere Regeln zu schaffen.
Für Ärger sorgt der Verkehr.
Massen von Reisecars
zu jeder Tageszeit.
Zudem kommen viele Gäste
mit Mietautos,
obwohl sie überfordert sind
mit den hiesigen Verkehrsregeln.
* Unverständliche Rufe *
Für die arabischen Gäste gibt's
übrigens inzwischen ein Erklärvideo,
wie man sich
in Interlaken verhalten soll.
U.a.: bei Rot - anhalten.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
Die Touristiker vor Ort sagen,
es sei nachvollziehbar,
dass im Sommer manche Einheimische
einen gewissen Dichtestress
verspürten.
Aber von Problemen wie
in Venedig oder Barcelona
sei man noch weit entfernt,
den sog. Overtourism gebe es nicht.
Ich finde es
ein überstrapaziertes Thema.
Nur während der absoluten Topsaison,
ich nenne Juli und August,
dann nimmt man es wahr.
Aber als Einheimischer
hat man genug Möglichkeiten,
auszuweichen
oder etwas anderes zu unternehmen.
Man muss dann keine Hotspots
wie z.B. den Höheweg besuchen,
der trotzdem wunderschön
zum Flanieren ist.
Während der anderen Monate
ist ein überstrapaziertes Thema.
Im Winter haben wir
immer noch leere Hotelbetten.
Ausweichen tut auch sie,
Annemarie Maeder,
Teamleiterin in einem Altersheim.
Wenn sie an ihrem freien Tag
walken geht,
dann schnellstmöglich weg
vom überlaufenen Zentrum.
Dort muss ich
zu sehr aufpassen und achtgeben.
Ich gehe laufen,
um meinen Kopf etwas zu lüften,
damit ich meine Ruhe habe.
Dann mag ich nicht Schlangenlinien
laufen oder ausweichen.
Noch vor ein paar Jahren ging ich
mit Besuch am Wochenende gerne
über die Höhematte,
weil das eine Attraktion war.
Heute geht man nicht mehr dorthin.
Man flieht an die Aare,
an den See oder in die Berge.
Mir wird es zu viel inmitten
all dieser Massen von Leuten.
Dabei komme ich mir manchmal
selbst wie ein Tourist vor.
Der Höheweg ist tatsächlich
seit Jahren in Touristenhand.
Sehen Sie, überall Inder.
Wir haben eine Gruppe
von 600 Leuten mitgebracht.
Manche Einheimische sagen,
es gebe inzwischen zu viele Gäste?
Aber das ist doch
wichtig für die Einnahmen.
Das Geld der Feriengäste
ist doch wertvoll - überall.
Wir wären in Indien
sehr froh darüber.
Wir werden das bei uns
auch schaffen.
Sind die Einheimischen
nett zu Ihnen?
Einheimische?
Wir haben keine Möglichkeit,
Einheimische zu treffen.
Sie sehen keine?
Nein, wir sehen sie nicht.
Sind Sie einheimisch?
- Ja, schon.
Manche Leute hier sagen,
es gebe zu viele Touristen?
Es kommt darauf an,
wohin Sie gehen.
In Luzern, ja,
da sind zu viele Touristen.
Aber wenn du nach Appenzell fährst
oder nach Pontresina,
dort triffst du
die echten Schweizer.
Und die sind so nett.
Ganz Asien ist hier vertreten.
Sind Sie das erste Mal hier?
- Nein, wir waren schon öfters hier.
Und hat es sich verändert?
Ja, es hat sich verändert -
eher zum Nachteil.
Es sind sehr viele Leute,
einfach zu viele jetzt.
Und doch: Das Geschäft läuft.
Von den Unternehmern
hört man fast keine Klagen.
Im Gegenteil: Asiaten und Araber
geben mehr Geld aus als Europäer.
* Poppige Ziehharmonikamusik *
Im Moment läuft der Textilverkauf
wahnsinnig gut.
T-Shirts sind im Moment der Hit.
Nach ein paar Jahren Baisse
können wir wieder
sehr viele T-Shirts verkaufen.
Wieso?
Wir haben ein super Design.
Auch Preis und Leistung stimmt eben.
Und das Zweite, das
unheimlich gut läuft, sind Magnete.
Kühlschrankmagnete
sind seit Jahren ein Hit.
Wo werden diese hergestellt?
In der Schweiz?
Nein.
- Aus China?
Ja.
Dann könnten Sie diese
an sich direkt in China verkaufen.
Ja, ja.
Die Chinesen, die hierher kommen ...
... kaufen ein chinesisches Produkt,
das sie wieder
zurück nach China nehmen.
Es ist etwas ...
Es ist leider so.
An die 90 % der Einheimischen
arbeiten in der Gemeinde Interlaken
im Dienstleistungssektor.
Der Souvenirladenbetreiber kann
das Klagen nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich kann die Einheimischen
nicht ganz verstehen.
Ich rede jetzt
über den Standort Interlaken.
Interlaken lebt
seit eh und je vom Tourismus.
Zu viel? Was ist zu viel?
Wir müssen auch leben, oder?
Wenn keine Touristen mehr kommen,
ist dieses Dorf,
dieses Städtchen hier tot.
Das müssen wir klar sehen.
Hätte man lieber
die Deutschen und Engländer zurück
und weniger Araber oder Asiaten?
Nein, aus meiner Sicht Nein.
Ich finde einen guten Mix
etwas vom Schönsten.
Das zeigt, dass wir auf der Welt
miteinander auskommen könnten.
Hier kommen alle miteinander aus.
Hier laufen Israeli an Arabern
vorbei, ohne sich zu prügeln.
Jede Religion kauft hier ein
und hat hier Spass in den Ferien.
Hier funktioniert es.
Ich hätte es lieber noch bunter und
gemischter. Das wäre noch schöner.
Aber das sehen nicht alle im Dorf so?
Nein, das ist leider ein
politisches Problem. Ja, das stimmt.
Hinten im Tal diskutiere ich oft,
werde von Bauern angesprochen:
"Die Araber,
dieses Pack soll verschwinden."
Ich bin eben anders,
bin ein offener Mensch.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl,
dass diese Leute Verbrecher sind,
die kommen sowieso nicht hierher.
Das sind richtig gute Leute,
die hierher kommen.
Unsere letzte Station: Harder Kulm,
der Hausberg von Interlaken.
Im Volksmund inzwischen
Araberberg genannt.
Mäeli Aruda und ihr Mann
Sulejman aus Saudi Arabien
sind schon zum zweiten Mal
in der Schweiz
und sie bleiben gleich zwei Wochen.
Ich habe auf Snapchat ein Foto
veröffentlicht und geschrieben:
Wir sind im Paradies.
Das hier ist
doch das Paradies der ganzen Welt.
Ihre Frau ist ja verhüllt.
Gibt das Probleme?
Nein, es gibt überhaupt
keine Probleme. Alle grüssen uns.
Niemand fragt, was das soll.
Es sind freundliche Leute.
Den Weg ins vermeintliche Paradies
sollen in Zukunft
noch viel mehr Menschen finden.
Wer jetzt schon
von Dichtstress spricht,
muss sich auf etwas gefasst machen.
Der Chef des Harder Kulm
erwartet noch viel mehr Touristen.
Wir sind noch völlig am Anfang
einer Entwicklung,
die in den nächsten Jahren
auf uns zukommen wird.
Die Jungfraubenahn
haben diese Entwicklung angetrieben,
dass wir diesen Erfolg jetzt haben.
Aber jetzt beginnt es erst,
jetzt kommen die Leute von selbst.
In fünf bis sechs Jahren
werden Sie fürs Jungfraujoch,
die First oder den Harder Kulm
einen Tag im Voraus
reservieren müssen,
damit Sie überhaupt
hinauf kommen.
Die Leute kommen
aus der ganzen Welt.
Wenn die Visumspflichten in Indien
oder den asiatischen Ländern fallen,
wenn für diese Leute
das Reisen noch einfacher wird ...
Deshalb befinden uns
so gesehen erst am Anfang.